what should I know about you you're a
writer
pitch me may I ask where you last worked
I worked in the mayor's office
Dave I've been working for more than a
year now I just I think that I could be
releasable with this sort of thing you
know you don't get to the end of your
own day - just because you showed up at
day one hello you called but said you
wanted to meet in person about your
story we're not taking the story unless
we can see the video can you imagine the
uproar Hey
sorry do work here I'm just an assistant
so how does this video come your way
what am I looking at it's a good story
everyone's story is always a good story
until it's not well if you like it I'm
pitching it with Jesus Christ you have
to give me a couple of days before you
do anything here you think it's real I
don't know when you're asked your
opinion you have to have one
what were you looking for I don't know I
thought that maybe somebody might know
something do you know what kind of
traffic is composing the site you won't
use my name
I really hope whoever tells your story
tells it right maybe you're just not a
very good journalist one of them is
gonna get it they sandwich the guy was
asking we could offer them or offer them
more could you make maybe you're just
not a very good journalist if you come
out with this that's my story
this is insane pitch me mother's day
they got to it first you know what
happens if this late at least pitch me
seriously this is my story maybe you're
just modifying a journalist do not pitch
stories you are a sign thing it was just
another day it's just another woman your
story - Gary
and that's everything you know
is he gonna lose his job he's the mayor
is that a yes or no
[Music]
you
[Music]
you